oh okay well if you buy like chocolate
all that it's like sweets
do you know what we call them in
australia oh yeah we all right
no no no we have we if they're lollipops
yeah do you want juicer to all candies
all candy
oh so we refer to lollies as just
lollipops yeah yeah yeah but in
australia they're all call lollies
there's this infamous like meme photo of
me from like back in the day where i'm
at australia
i'm at an airport in sydney and i just
thought it was really funny i just posed
next to this sign that just said bagged
lollies and i just like just did that
and it's like made its rounds on like
meanwhile i'm glad that the lollipop is
the worst candy of all time it is now i
can say i hate lollies in every sense
it is no i i remember when i used to get
it at like age
10 they'd give you a lollipop you're
like for [ __ ] sake it's the cola
flavored [ __ ] lollipop
i like the cola flavored ones [ __ ] that
sucks you mean the chopper chops right
yeah
the chocolate chops no [ __ ] off cola
cola flavored sweets
are just not it's like eating
hard flat coke and that's that's that's
the best way i can describe it
like flat coke is bad enough as it is
let's make it hard i never liked
who liked lollipops they [ __ ] sucked
i mean i'm not going to go out of my way
to eat a [ __ ] chopper shops now yeah
now but i won't complain excuse me it
was made to like
make kids eat sweets for a long time
that yeah aren't actually like at a lot
of sweets
yeah i was smart i realized this is
waste this is not optimized
i can i can i can eat way more i have
teeth to break this down yeah
i hated it i'd never go for the
lollipops what's your favorite type of
candy
uh the one that you always go back i
think chocolate is the best sweet like
thing yeah but that's often not
considered like candy yeah
it's kind of in its own thing yeah yeah
i really like the um haribo i love
sour haribo were pretty [ __ ] good i
like haribo
um anything i like the laces you know oh
the sour like strips sour laces oh the
sour strips the rainbow sour strips
those things slap i love those in
australia did you have like the penny
sweets
where you like any sweets yeah we had
this in the uk yeah where you go to like
a
literally a [ __ ] candy store and you
get given a bag and you just like
fill it up oh yes yes yeah yeah yeah
yeah i mean those
i i think those [ __ ] candy slaps oh
yeah well we we have
the biggest one in wales is like in my
town and it's literally the size of this
set
that's huge i mean considering every
single wall is candy
it's good and they used to have these
like really [ __ ] sour things like
they're like the most sour
sweet in the world yeah yeah yeah yeah
they're just dunked in that [ __ ]
horrible sour stuff you gave us that one
video
yeah it's just fun i love sour candy man
yeah sour candy is my favorite but it's
awful though because you can't drink
anything afterwards and waters taste bad
water tastes sweet right yeah i kind of
like that though
i don't know why it's something about
that where it's like every other
drink tastes like absolute [ __ ] yeah but
like when the water is sweet i'm just
like oh
yeah i mean it's kind of nice yeah i
mean i i don't think it's that bad it's
[ __ ] it's [ __ ] water
it's just water bro